all right good people of the internet
we're doing an impromptu livestream
today and the reason we're doing that is
yesterday something pretty bizarre I
guess if these were normal political
times happen but sort of kind of obvious
in these wacky times were in and also
also kind of inspiring actually happened
yesterday so before I introduce my
guests I want to play it's about a two
and a half minute clip Joe Biden the
presumptive Democratic nominee for
president he was at the Fiat Chrysler
plant in Detroit yesterday meeting with
union workers and guys that work over at
the factory over there and then
something happened so let's take a look
these union workers they have been
working countless hours on the Trump
administration I'd like you to explain
how you plan to not only keep us working
about how you intend on getting the
union vote when there's a large portion
of the union workers that are gun
enthusiasts and you are actively trying
to diminish your second Amendment right
and take away a gun here for [ __ ] I
support the second event
that's not my son anyway I'm not taking
your gun away at all you need a viral
video alright guys so the brave guy that
is talking to Joe Biden right there and
speaking to them quite respectfully
actually and bringing up completely
legitimate points and actually quoting
Joe Biden is a guy by the name of Jerry
Wayne and I've got Jerry Wayne on the
Skype right now
Jerry are you there yeah are you doing
I'm doing all right man first off you're
killing it in the beer game right now
the beard is appreciated thank you very
much appreciate it all right man so tell
me just how this whole thing transpired
before we even get into the specifics of
what we said when did you find out that
Biden was coming when did you decide
that you wanted to ask him something did
was it all just kind of chaos just lay
out the the beginnings of all this well
we start work at 7:00 a.m. and they
announced that he was going to be
stopping in in a couple hours
we all went to work and I just I kept
having things go off my
head of questions like I didn't think it
was going to be a questionnaire but I
didn't want to show up and not be
prepared and once once he did show up
and started going on shaking hands and
stuff like that he made his way to me
and I saw my opportunity to ask him a
question then everything that you saw
transpired were you kind of shocked that
he was so initially aggravated with you
or combative uh yeah I was I wasn't
expecting that reaction rather back I
kind of expected that a politician type
of roundabout and he didn't he came out
with just straight a blunt force and I
think that his uh his advisor next to
him I assume that's what she was I told
him to stop and he shook her and just
started to dig his own hole so before he
shushed her which was kind of
interesting and dismissive he
immediately said you're fully [ __ ] I
mean yes I've been expecting that one I
wasn't at all but I do do construction
and so I hear that all the time so I
can't say it was like a complete and
utter shock because to be honest with
you I'm an American citizen and I don't
see politicians as if they're above me I
I don't think a lot of people see it
that way but I'm not one of them they
they work for us and I think a lot of
people need to realize that yeah when
you said that to him towards the end
there you work for me man and he
completely dismissed that too
like is that just why everybody hates
politicians right now I think people
don't like politicians because they feel
as if that we work for them I think
that's the way America is looking at
things now and that needs to change
yeah did you happen to notice this is a
little technical but you know the fire
in a crowded theater line that he said
it's actually technically not true you
can yell fire in a crowded theater a lot
of people are confused by this I've been
confused it over yes you can't do it
with the intent to basically start a
riot or inste
yes you can just throw the children out
there it's okay to yell fire if there's
an actual fire as well yes if there's an
actual fire you got to do it so yes all
this is happening how did how nervous or
not nervous were you I mean this guy
wants to be the most powerful man
in the world and you were right up in
his face it does he wants me the most
powerful man in the world and maybe that
might not be his intention maybe he does
in his own mind want to do some good for
the world which is which is great
sure but I think every politician needs
to be reminded that America is the
strength not the individual I kind of
sense from the few minutes that we spoke
earlier this morning when I had to
verify it was you after you emailed me
and I was like all right you know I
can't just put this guy on I got to make
sure it's the same guy yeah I sense
you've kind of been ready to get your
voice out there like you know you don't
seem nervous now you you seem like a
clear thinker I saw you this morning on
Fox and Friends you mentioned Jordan
Peterson yeah yeah I may be I'm a quite
a big Jordan Pederson fan I know not
everybody may be but I am I think that
he's an intellectual and think he's one
of the greatest minds of our generation
well this generation not mine he's a
very smart man intellectual and he knows
how to put thoughts and theories
together in a very nice way so after the
whole thing goes down you guys have your
little brouhaha did you immediately go
oh [ __ ]
this thing's gonna go viral or you must
have seen oh I've been the rest of it I
did well I mean like I kind of had a
hunch that something would happen you
know like it's like it's media and
things are you blown up but then as well
I thought like it was just a
confrontation I'm just oh I'm just a guy
I didn't think that this would be blown
into such big proportion I mean there's
it's on the cover pages everywhere and
stuff and I had no idea this was
transpiring while I was going to work I
had some Inklings of things like hey man
like something's going big but I don't
have a service at work or anything like
that and when I get out of work by god
it definitely went went to the ceiling
for sure what we are guys saying to you
after were people impressed by what you
did we're people pissed did they think
you were being disrespectful I
definitely had a mixture for sure
I don't think everybody some people knew
I was gonna try to ask a question and
they tried talking me out of it but I
I'm an individual I'm an individual
finger I'm individual mind I'm gonna do
what I think is right and I wondered I
wanted to he came he came there because
he's a Democrat
and there's a lot of unions there and
usually the Union goes Democratic and by
the way in no way shape or form and I
represented it for any union whatsoever
I'm individual thing good and I think
that he wanted to show there I'm
Election Day and he wanted to wave to
everybody so hey look I showed face go
vote from me and get out of there but I
don't think he was ready for an
intellectual question take it outside
I mean what were you thinking that
wouldn't be the first time somebody said
that to him but you know what he said it
and that the thing is that I think
that's something small he was trying to
get me to grab on to to make me look
like I'm the bad guy
and that's not why I was there I was
there to make a point to the president I
don't know what he's talking about not
just president excuse me the
presidential candidate yeah he doesn't
know what he's talking about when it
comes to firearms and I think I think I
proved that point yeah so when he even
said to you that no I never said that
now you were referring to when he said
Tibet oh oh you're gonna handle guns for
me we all saw the video you said to him
no it's not edited video it's your own
words and he just basically flat-out
says no way I didn't say it I mean it's
almost like truth just doesn't bust
through to these people no not well I'm
not I'm not saying I'm signing for what
what these people are that people aren't
like that I the way I look at it as I
had a conversation with a different
individual he just so happens to be
trying to run for the president United
States and he's my peer he is not my
superior and I spoke to him and then on
an individual level
I - I and I wanted to call him out on
something but I the thing is is that
that wasn't the only question I asked
mm-hmm I was moral I was actually
worried about how he was going to
contribute to our our work we're working
very well right now we have countless
hours that were obtaining and we're
doing very well for ourselves and he
wants to come in there and he wants to
make it to where unions are better
I want you news to be better as well but
what is he gonna do I want to know what
is he going to change that makes our
lives better and he failed to answer
that as well
yeah can you tell me a little bit more
about just what you specifically deuce
I'm a millwright by trade
it's a rotating equipment we just work
on pretty much all types of machinery
and things of that nature
yeah where do you fall politically it's
sort of irrelevant to all of this but I
think it's sort of interesting just
generally speaking I know there's like a
lot of different parties right now I
don't think I fall under anyone
individually
I'm a lover and I think I think that
there needs to be a new political party
and it's that thin line I think that we
need to come together and I'm not gonna
go left I'm not gonna go right I I'm
American that's my party I love that man
you're speaking my language so thank you
has it has anyone else reached out to
you I mean I know you're on Fox and
Friends this morning I think you're
gonna be on Hannity this evening I was
supposed to be on tonight - by
coincidence they just booted me for
coronavirus but I hope I hope you're
gonna still be on there wondering
they're not putting me on above you they
booted me - all right well I'm in good
company I don't know about you yeah yeah
but I'm curious because if you look at
the way this is tracking on Twitter it
seemed like it was all sort of
conservatives or people on the right
that were making a big deal about this
and I saw basically some people on the
left and mainstream people kind of
defending Biden as if you were you know
being rude or something like that but
I'm wondering in terms of the media
that's reaching out to you because this
obviously broke through to the
mainstream is it only Fox and me I mean
as CNN reached out to you as MSNBC and
anyone main spur you know I have had
I've had some people reach out to me but
I gotta tell you why I've had so many
inquiries it's very hard to keep up with
everything like I am something like and
I hope I can use your platform to say
this some people I just I I tried to get
back and it just it there's a lot going
on right now I'm not used to this this
limelight and I'm just I'm trying to do
whatever I can to move the country
forward it's not my responsibility at
from what I see but it seems that a lot
of people are wanting me to be a voice
and I want to be a voice for the
American people if they want me to do it
yeah I love that answer man and
and I know you told me before that you
watch the show and it's like I've sat
across from a lot of people who didn't
necessarily want to get into the fight
but suddenly the fight kind of came to
them from James d'amour and Bret
Weinstein and Lindsay Sheppard and a
whole slew of people and I just get the
vibe from you like you're ready to get
in I I'm ready to do what the American
people want I'm just here to say what
the American people want to say and I
think that on I don't speak for either
side but I do believe that both sides
want a middle ground I believe that
that's what the America needs more than
anything and yeah I I'm a gun guy I am
and I think that I think that gun safety
starts at home and I think that we
shouldn't be looking away from this and
trying to take let me give an example I
train dogs on the side mm-hmm okay I'm
not I'm not trying to compare dogs to
humans any sense but if a dog chews
things and you come home and you just
cage that dog so it doesn't choose
things that dog still wants to choose
things you you you didn't fix that dog's
issue we just put a bandaid on it
and by by going with humans if you end
up if you end up taking the guns you
didn't fix the issue the underlying
problem of committing committing murder
you just took away an object that's all
you did so let's get to the underlying
issue here and let's fix what's actually
broken and that is that is the way
people are brought up and the way people
are treating each other I'm with you
Matt man you're preaching it because
that's it it's it's the psychological
stuff it's the societal stuff the
cultural stuff the gun that the AR 14 as
he got a 14 a r 14 is just is just the
tool really more than anything else yes
well I don't think that's the tool if he
was so adamant of saving American lives
he'd be going after handguns if that's
really what really what his his goal was
but they don't want to look at that they
don't want to look at the facts
I shouldn't say they I should say he he
doesn't want to look at the facts and
the facts are that's what kills people
and he excused me a losing my train
here um now please go ahead here I'll
bring you back around using a segue here
watch this is a professional Segway you
know there's a lot of talk right now
about Biden's cognitive stuff and that
he's bumbling and fumbling and
forgetting what he's saying and the rest
of it as someone that stood you know six
inches away with you with his finger
right in your face you know guy wants to
be the most powerful man in the world
since did you sense any of that I know
you're not a doctor or anything then I
sense what exactly that something maybe
is not quite right okay hell of a segue
yeah I I don't think I I'm not a doctor
and I I'm gonna respectfully not speak
on that I don't notice a anything that I
yeah that I'm gonna shoot myself in the
foot with that I don't know I'm not a
doctor and that's first time I met him I
don't know how it was 15 years ago in a
personal sense and compared to no
totally fair answer man I appreciate the
honesty you are ready to reel in this
bigger world I can said is there
anything else you want to share you got
a lot of people that are gonna know you
now from this that from what happened
yesterday anything else you want people
to know about you what you do the Union
situation guns really anything no I
didn't for a minute I didn't want to
speak on this I think I might want to
know I've been a union guy for about
eleven years now gaana when I was 18
years old and very active you new member
I've had some ups and I'm has some downs
my dues are on time and I want to let
the Union the regular union worker know
that you have an individual mind and you
can make up your mind your Union does
not make up your mind you make up your
Union and people need to realize that if
you want to be Democrat Republican left
right center it doesn't matter you make
up your own mind they work for you you
do not work for them love it love it
well listen to this I want to pay it
forward a little bit cuz I think what
you did yesterday was seriously brave
and we need more people like out there
so my tour is gonna have a Detroit stop
I think it's May 10th or 12th I'm
forgetting off the top of my head I
believe it's at the Fillmore I want to
give you and your girlfriend free the
VIP tickets come backstage
want to come on stage with me we'll do
it open I would love to that'd be great
all right I'm gonna bring you up on
stage and listen any of your guys that
were there yesterday or any of your
buddies that want to come if they just
got a regular ticket will upgrade
everybody for VIP I'd love to just shake
all their hands and maybe I can come to
my mind we might a little more man dude
let's fill the film or why not right I
got a lot of friends now Oh actually I
don't want to ask you one other thing
related to that what are you shocked at
any of the the hate you're getting I I
hate to end there so I'll ask you one
other thing after but much you mentioned
to me you're getting some hate yeah I'm
getting some hate on social media for
sure but I think that whenever you're in
the limelight you can't make everybody
happy but what you can do is you can
follow it you can follow your soul you
can follow your intuition if you're
leading that right you're gonna go down
the right path and I can't make
everybody happy
I can't and that's not then north is
that my job my I feel as if it's my
purpose to uh to share my perspective on
things
I'm not the brightest guy I'm not like
I'm not the sharpest knife in the drawer
but uh I try and I care about this
country very much and I want to bring
this country together and if I'm the
first drop of glue that has to let that
happen I'll be that drop listen man it's
an honor truly talking to you I think
you're the real deal I think you're
ready I think this is just the beginning
I'm gonna send this video to Jordan
myself so he will he will see this I
promise you that and anything I can
anything I can do for you and I'll see
you in Detroit thank you very much I
appreciate your time all right thanks
man good luck with everything Jerry yeah
thank you all right bye-bye
all right guys I don't even know how
could I add anything to that I mean I
don't know I appreciate it man thank you
very much yeah yeah
are we still live streaming we're still
live streaming there's nothing there's
truly nothing I can add to that that
that was just real deal
a human who just kind of stepped into
something and seems to be ready to keep
going so I have nothing to add to it his
name's Jerry Wayne it was at the Fiat
Chrysler facility in destroy in Detroit
sorry if I'm speaking a little slow I'm
getting a little feedback on my earpiece
here we're gonna work on that but anyway
I think he's on Twitter now I'm gonna
tweet out his ad handle so you can give
him a follow and the games continue
everybody thanks for watching